[MUSIC PLAYING]
KATE LEAHY: Thank you for
such a nice, warm welcome.
It's wonderful to be at this
campus on such a beautiful day.
We're so spoiled
in the Bay Area.
So again, my name is
Kate Leahy, and I'm
a San Francisco based cookbook
author and food writer.
Desmond, I think what's
one of the great stories
is how you ended up
owning a restaurant called
Burma Superstar to begin with.
DESMOND TAN: Well, I
didn't name the name--
I didn't name the
restaurant Burma Superstar.
I purchased it from a gentleman
who operated Burma Superstar.
It was a failing
Burmese restaurant.
It just happened one
day, I was eating there
on Saturday
afternoon about 1:00.
And someone walked in, and he
was a little bit hysterical,
and then just found out that
Burma Superstar was sold.
I'm thinking, shit, what
am I going to eat now?
And in those days, there
were no Burmese restaurants.
There was Burma Superstar,
and there was Mandalay.
And I can think of another one
in Philadelphia, one in DC,
two in New York,
and that was it.
And no one knew Burma.
No one knew Burma Superstar,
Burmese food, or anything.
So to make the long story
short, I was just thinking,
OK, you know, like, I
wanted to know what's going
to happen to the restaurant.
I got the owner's
phone number to see
if he might be interested
in selling it to me
so that I could keep it
as a Burmese restaurant.
It was sold to a
Chinese gentleman.
I think he was going to turn
that into a Chinese restaurant.
So my conversation with him was,
can you back out of the deal?
So I could pay you maybe a
little bit more, 10%, 15%.
And what he said
was, OK, hang on.
Let me see what I can do.
So on the next day--
I went there on
Saturday, Sunday-- he
called me back about at 10:00
PM, when I was in my office.
And he said, hey,
you know, there
might be a way where I
could get out of the deal,
and come and take a look at it.
So I made arrangements
to go look
at the restaurant on Monday.
And if you're looking at a hole
in the wall place, that was it.
I mean, that was really
a hole in the wall.
KATE LEAHY: Well,
because one of the things
was, at that time,
Clement Street,
that part of Clement
Street, was really quiet.
No one went onto that
part of Clement Street
to go out to eat, right?
It was just the quiet
side of the street.
DESMOND TAN: It
was the quiet side.
There were cafes, and I think
there were young kids that
hangs out after school.
Yeah, I would say Clement
Street was a second Chinatown.
And it was in a busy space.
I'd simply just wanted a Burmese
restaurant to stay Burmese,
and to eat Burmese food
with my family and friends.
So I went there on
Monday, looked at it,
and thought about it, and
called him back on Tuesday.
And on Wednesday, we
have a restaurant.
So it was funny.
Pretty quick-- that all happened
within, I think, four days.
KATE LEAHY: And
that was in 2000?
And the restaurant was
originally opened--
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, in 2000.
KATE LEAHY: --in 1992.
So it had been operating--
DESMOND TAN: Seven years.
KATE LEAHY: Yeah, but--
because you grew up in--
well, part of your growing
up was in the inner Richmond
neighborhood in San Francisco.
But the other part
was in Yangon.
DESMOND TAN: In Yangon, right.
Yeah, I mean, also growing up,
because there were no Burmese
food, the only Burmese food
I would get would be from
my mom's.
And I didn't cook,
and I don't cook.
And my mom would ask me,
what will you eat when I die?
And now, we have
six restaurants.
She doesn't ask me
that question anymore.
KATE LEAHY: That's true.
Right.
Because when you were growing
up, before you came to the US,
it was all the girls
who would learn
how to cook in the kitchen.
And the boys were off the hook.
So you just learned how
to be a really good eater.
DESMOND TAN: A good cleaner--
KATE LEAHY: And
good cleaner, yeah.
DESMOND TAN: --a
good cleaner, right.
I learned about
food just basically
from eating, eating a lot of
it, and just understanding
the flavors.
KATE LEAHY: What are
the kind of, for you,
what are the most nostalgic
flavors about Burmese food,
the kind of things when
you smell or you taste
it or you just think that,
that really reminds me
of your childhood?
DESMOND TAN: It
will be the curries.
Curries are a little bit
different from Chinese curries,
Korean curries, Indian curries.
I think the closest
to Burmese curry,
I mean, if I have
to compare, would
be Southern Indian curries,
light, a little bit
lighter in flavor,
masala, spicy.
But the other one
would be a mohinga,
which is a catfish
stew-like type of dish,
served with noodles.
And it's a dish that you
stew for a couple of hours,
the catfish, until the
catfish is broken down.
Maybe you could explain a
little bit more about that.
KATE LEAHY: Yeah,
well, what I love
about the story about mohinga
is that people order this dish.
It's sort of a
sleeper on the menu.
It's a quieter dish.
But when you go
to visit Myanmar--
I mean, and we should probably
talk a little bit about just
the name, just to clarify.
So when you lived in that
country, it was called Burma.
DESMOND TAN: Burma.
KATE LEAHY: And you had
already moved to the US.
And then the government
changed the name to Myanmar.
So in the cookbook, when
we refer to your childhood,
we talk about Burma.
When we refer the country in
present day, we say, Myanmar.
And one of the reasons,
though, is in 2012,
President Obama actually
called the country Myanmar.
And that started a change
in Western countries,
referring to the
country as Myanmar.
But back to something more fun--
mohinga.
When you go visit Yangon,
the first thing you see
is all the street vendors.
It's mohinga.
It's like the pho.
It's like you see-- it's a
very popular street food.
You eat it for breakfast.
Now you eat it for lunch and
dinner, it's become so popular.
But it's really relatively
unknown in the United States.
And no one's really
heard of mohinga.
People come in for good
reason at Burma Superstar
to order the tea leaf salad.
But mohinga kind
of gets left aside,
because you don't
know what it is.
So when people order it, they
think, oh, I'm getting catfish.
And then they get it, and
they go, well, where's the--
DESMOND TAN: Yeah,
where's the beef?
KATE LEAHY: --catfish?
Yeah, where's the beef?
So I learned how to prepare it.
I watched a couple of the
cooks in the restaurants,
as well as an aunt of Desmond's.
And I saw how they
prepared mohinga.
And there's lots
of ways to do it.
But the key is you
get a whole catfish,
and that becomes the base of the
broth, the stock that you make.
And you cook that catfish.
Then you take the meat off.
You put the bones back.
You simmer that.
You strain that broth.
And then you take
the catfish meat
and cook it with aromatics.
And all of it gets
combined, but you're
kind of crushing
the catfish meat.
So the soup is thick and rich.
You won't see the catfish.
But it's definitely in there.
But it's just that it's a really
rich, soul-satisfying dish
of noodles, broth, catfish.
And in other parts of Myanmar,
they have their own variation.
There's local
variations everywhere.
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, [INAUDIBLE].
KATE LEAHY: Yeah, yeah.
So in the cookbook,
we decided it
was such an important
dish for the country,
that we included two.
So you have your option of doing
a spicier, more seafood-based.
You don't have to use catfish.
You could use more of
a seafood type of fish.
I mean, the fish
you get locally is
so different from
the fish you get
in other parts of
the world, that you
can be flexible with the fish.
But the aromatics
are what change
from the Rakhine mohinga,
where Rakhine is a state--
DESMOND TAN: Coastal.
KATE LEAHY: Yeah, coastal state.
And they're cut off from
the rest of the country
with this wall of mountains.
So they use a lot more
seafood in their cooking.
And their cooking
is a lot spicier.
So we put a lot of
chilies in there.
It's a lovely broth.
It's just two
different variations.
And if you look at the
cookbook, the back cover
is the Rakhine mohinga.
And then within the
cookbook, the picture
that has the sort of
an essay on mohinga,
that's the classic,
Burma Superstar version.
That would be the version that
would be inspired by Yangon.
But it's your
favorite dish, right?
DESMOND TAN: It is,
curries, coconut rice.
KATE LEAHY: And your daughter's.
DESMOND TAN: Yeah,
my daughter eats it.
This is her favorite dish also.
Rather than what I think
that people want to hear,
are there any questions
that people want to ask?
KATE LEAHY: Well,
one thing I'll ask--
well, let's actually talk
about how the recipes came
to be in the cookbook, because
I think this is something
that we joke about a lot when
I started working with you.
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, so when
we started working with Kate,
Kate would ask me, can
I see the recipe book?
I'd say, we actually
don't have a recipe book.
And then Kate wouldn't
believe that we
don't have a recipe book.
And we actually don't,
considering that we
have all these restaurants.
And I think it's
a funny situation.
Because we have a lot
of people who've been
with us for 10, 15, 20 years.
And they know how to
do different stations,
do different things.
And we've never had any
problems with having
the food to be consistent,
because they've just been there
for a while.
They know exactly what to do.
And we've never
had a need for it.
So Kate came on.
All of a sudden, we
have a recipe book.
KATE LEAHY: Right, right.
So at lot of times,
when I start working
with a chef on a
cookbook, these chefs,
they have their recipes
written down in some fashion.
Some cookbooks--
I mean, some chefs
have them written
in just a notebook.
And then I have to
look at all their--
I have to figure out
what their shorthand is.
Like one chef I worked with,
Mindy Segal, in Chicago--
she's a pastry chef--
and she would just write
V-E-X. It's like, what's V-E-X?
She's like, oh, that's
pure vanilla extract.
It's like, all right, so vex.
Now, I think vex and vanilla.
All right, I'm fine.
But I didn't even
have that to work off.
So other chefs have
these long spreadsheets
of all the different variations
you can do with the dish,
and it's all measured
out to the gram.
And with those kinds
of recipes, what
I do is I have to cut
them down and make sure
you can do that in a
portion that serves 4 to 6
instead of 20 to 50.
So this time, though, I just
had to go into the restaurants
and meet with the
different cooks.
And that's the
one thing, though.
There's not one chef
of all the restaurants.
There are kitchen
managers and cooks.
And all these cooks
are cross-trained
on all the stations.
And what's fascinating is all of
them speak different languages.
Even the ones who
came from Myanmar
speak different local languages.
Because the country, which
is pretty fascinating--
I mean, I didn't know this,
coming in from the outside--
there's 135 ethnic
groups in Myanmar
that are officially recognized.
And there's a lot more
that go unrecognized.
So you have a very,
very diverse population.
I mean, so it's almost
like an Asian melting pot.
DESMOND TAN: Where it's
situated is interesting,
because it's right
between India and China.
Really it's where
China meets India.
On one side, you have a
billion plus population.
On the other side, you still
have over a billion population.
So it's really interesting.
And just from that
alone, that put aside,
there are about 130
different ethnic groups
and a lot of Indian
immigration in the early 1900s,
because of the
huge economic boom.
When the English
took over, I think
there were a couple
of millions of Indians
that immigrated in
the early 1900s.
But also, Chinese immigrated
around that time, a couple
hundred thousand [INAUDIBLE].
And around that time,
the Burma was the--
Yangon port was the most
prosperous port country
really in that region.
Because around that
time, of a lot of people
went over to Burma.
KATE LEAHY: I mean,
before World War II,
the biggest rice
exporter in the world
was Burma, which is just
kind of crazy to even fathom.
DESMOND TAN: Right.
So the diversity
with the population--
and just because Burmese
food is interesting.
Because the Burma borders
Thailand, India, China,
Bangladesh, and so forth, you
get a lot of different spices
from those places.
And at the same time, Burmese
food is uniquely Burmese.
The tea leaf salad, mohinga,
that you can't get anywhere.
But then there are
a lot of dishes
that will remind
you of Thai food,
the Indian food, Chinese
food, and so forth.
KATE LEAHY: And one thing
I like about the recipes
is that a lot of them
are very doable at home.
This is home cooking, but then
was remade to fit a restaurant.
So what we talked
a lot about was
how to reintroduce
it to home cooking.
And if anyone's ever looked at
a Thai curry recipe that had,
I don't know, 100 ingredients,
and you make this paste,
this is sort of a nice
respite from that.
You can make this, and you
don't need to source a lot
of hard to find ingredients.
If you have onions and garlic
and turmeric and paprika,
you can go pretty
far with this book,
which there are the exceptions.
But in general, a lot
of the flavor profiles,
you can find at most
local grocery stores,
now that fish sauce is
so widely available.
And fish sauce-- shrimp paste
might be a little harder.
But it's not in every recipe.
And I know sometimes,
it's an acquired taste.
But it really is such-- like
shrimp paste, the salty--
DESMOND TAN: Spicy.
KATE LEAHY: --spicy, savory
flavors are really what, to me,
I think of as Burmese food.
It doesn't have
the sweet flavors
that you might think
of in Thai cooking.
DESMOND TAN: Yeah,
I think the fish
sauce are popping up everywhere
nowadays, with the Red Boat.
KATE LEAHY: And well, Italians
are putting fish sauce--
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, I know.
KATE LEAHY: --in their
tomato sauce now.
DESMOND TAN: And shrimp
paste might be nice.
I think just how much you put in
it, I think, with Burmese food,
people use it.
And it is very flavorful
and really pungent.
And I'm not sure
people have adopted
to the shrimp past flavors, but
I think a lot of people are--
they're traveling, they're
tasting, they're trying.
And I'm seeing that at
local stores everywhere.
KATE LEAHY: One thing I
wanted to ask you about,
too, is just--
let's talk about tea leaf salad.
I mean, it's something that
Burma Superstar is known for.
It's something that,
I don't know, was--
you explain it-- maybe
a Samsonite ingredient
for many years?
The country was closed
off from the world.
You couldn't legally export
something from Myanmar
straight to the United States.
It had to go through
these different channels.
DESMOND TAN: So because Burma
was a sanctioned country
for the last 50, 60 years,
you couldn't get anything out
of Burma.
So if you received
products from Burma,
it might be a product
of Thailand or Malaysia
or Singapore,
India, and so forth.
Because normally, it
will go to those states
or those countries, and from
there, the country of origin
disappears.
It becomes a product
of Thailand, Singapore,
and so forth.
So the way that we've
been getting the tea
leaf, in the past, was
whoever goes back to Burma,
bring back some tea leaf salad.
And bring them back
with their luggages.
KATE LEAHY:
Samsonite ingredient.
DESMOND TAN: And thanks
to the tea label,
I think that we've been
able to just get the product
without any problems.
KATE LEAHY: But how
did you do that?
How did you find the right
people to be able to?
DESMOND TAN: Well, it became
a pretty lucrative business
for them.
We own several restaurants.
We started selling just a lot
of tea leaves in our restaurant.
KATE LEAHY: Tell me about the
where the tea leaf is grown.
DESMOND TAN: The tea
leaf that we were getting
are not the best quality.
I think the coloring
that they use
to keep it green was
questionable; preservatives.
And I love MSG, but in those
packets, they were 10%, 15%.
That was a little
bit too much for me.
And we wanted to give our
customers a better product.
So we started looking around.
We started looking around
and asked different people,
how do you make
the tea leaf salad?
And what's really interesting
is that the tea leaf
salad is ubiquitous in Burma.
Everybody, they all eat it.
They eat it for a
snack; kids, adults.
You go there.
You see that everywhere.
How many people have
been to Burma in here?
KATE LEAHY: Did you see the
tea leaf salad there, or a tea
leaf, in general?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
DESMOND TAN: So
everybody eat it.
It's everywhere.
KATE LEAHY: I remember
seeing it in the snap packs.
You get tea leaf itself--
lahpet as they call
it in Myanmar--
but the tea leaf salads
in these little snack
packs, that you could think
of like someone buying
a pack of chips,
but instead, they're
buying a pack of tea leaves.
Then they will just
throwing in the crunchies,
the fried garlic,
maybe some peanuts.
DESMOND TAN: That's
their caffeine.
KATE LEAHY: Yeah,
that's your caffeine.
So here are students studying.
DESMOND TAN: A savory caffeine.
KATE LEAHY: Just get a
little packet of tea leaf.
DESMOND TAN: So
we asked everybody
in San Francisco,
Burmese people,
how do you ferment the tea?
How do you make the tea?
Nobody knows.
So we went to Yangon.
How do you make it?
Nobody knows.
It's just really strange.
Everybody eat it, but they
don't know how it's made.
And if you have any
Burmese friend, ask them.
I challenge you, that they
will know how it's done.
So anybody from Burma here?
Nobody.
OK.
So we ended up in
the Shan state,
which is a very conflicted
area and one of the largest
ethnic region in Burma.
They want their
independent state.
The North want their
own independence.
The South, they want
their own independence.
It's a fairly
remote jungle area.
And then you have
these drug warlords
who wants their own area.
KATE LEAHY: It's part of
the Golden Triangle region.
DESMOND TAN: Right.
And then the Burmese
government, they are all--
there are four military groups.
They're always there fighting.
So it's an interesting
area to go.
KATE LEAHY: Interesting is
a good way to put it, yeah.
DESMOND TAN: So, well, that's
where we get our tea from.
So we go up to the most
northern part of Shan state,
a region called
Namhsan just arguably
probably where the best
tea from Burma comes from.
So we go.
We take the small plane to
get to this certain area,
and from there, drive
another 6, 7 hours
to this mountainous area, and to
the tea region called Namhsan.
KATE LEAHY: The
way I always think
of it is, Namhsan if people
think of wine and terroir,
and they talk about
soil types, when
you think of Namhsan,
where the tea is grown,
it's a sandy type of
soil that drains well,
that is ideal for
the type of tea
that you pick,
and then ferments.
It's not the same
as for black tea.
Black tea, at least in
that part of the world,
grows better in soil
that has more clay.
So the type of soil makes
Namhsan particularly
great for this type of tea.
And we were looking at different
samples of the tea leaves
when they're dry.
You could tell the ones
that had the brighter, more
of a yellow kind of
color, gold color.
Those were sort of-- you
get a higher price for that.
That's supposedly
the higher quality.
DESMOND TAN: Tea buds.
KATE LEAHY: The real dark ones
with the really big leaves,
those are sort of a
lesser quality tea leaf.
DESMOND TAN: Well, in Burma,
so the quality ones you
are speaking of are called--
they're tea buds.
And people refer to do
those as tea for generals.
KATE LEAHY: [LAUGHING]
DESMOND TAN: But
those people are
the only one who can afford it.
KATE LEAHY: But what's really
cool is, for the longest time,
people who were tea farmers,
they had a hard time.
They used brokers in Mandalay.
Mandalay's the biggest
trading, agricultural trading,
city in the country.
And the tea brokers sometimes
wouldn't pay the tea farmers
until they had sold
all the product.
So you had these tea farmers.
Maybe they'd do a whole,
three different, four
different, harvests
during the year.
And then they wouldn't
get paid for a year.
So it's no wonder that
maybe picking opium
became a good option for them.
Now, you're working with a
tea co-op, a newly-formed tea
co-op, that's now
giving more power
to the farmers themselves.
Getting more education
from the outside world, now
that the country
is opening up, they
can learn better plant
management techniques.
At the same time,
they've always been
organic, which is pretty great.
So they didn't have to take
away a lot of pesticides.
They didn't have money for
pesticides, to begin with.
The jungle tea was growing
in a wild type of way.
So in a way,
because they skipped
a lot of this
modern agriculture,
they actually benefit
in the modern.
DESMOND TAN: Correct.
It's just an interesting
market, because the brokers
were paying them also
so little, to a point
where, aside from
these crazy terms,
they were getting very little.
So they were going to
China to do farming work,
abandoning their farm,
which is a little crazy,
to think the Chinese pay
more money than Burmese.
So you can imagine how little
they were getting paid.
So what we did was we paid them
whatever that we were paying
the brokers, a little bit more,
and also work with the farmers
to organize an association
where we buy the tea from.
And the farmers go sell their
tea at that association,
and we buy it from there.
And so they don't
have to negotiate
with the farmer, the brokers.
So the farmers in
Burma are probably
a little bit different
from the farmers in US.
They don't have a lot of land.
They're probably micro farmers.
Mostly, they're micro farmers,
and they're not wealthy.
They're really poor.
And they're not sophisticated.
So when you negotiate, you
just pay whatever price
that the brokers were paying.
And also, the terms are
ridiculous, as you were saying.
They don't get paid
until it's sold.
KATE LEAHY: Can
you imagine if you
didn't get paid until a
year after the work you did?
It's like, how would you live?
How would you buy food?
DESMOND TAN: So things
are changing a little bit.
I think that we're also
introducing the organic farming
to them.
We are working towards
providing soil.
Because they are
harvesting, but they're
not taking care of their land.
That also means that the
yield is not that great.
I think that, if we introduce
certain farming methods,
I think that they can yield
far greater than whatever
it is that they're
getting at the moment.
KATE LEAHY: So one of
the things in the book,
this is not about tea, but
it's related to that area.
There's a salad.
Well, we use the term
salad pretty loosely.
Salad can mean a lot
of different things
in Burmese cooking.
But it's a salad
made with, basically,
shredded, dried mutton.
So we can use it in the states.
We can use beef jerky.
And it's just shallots and lime
juice and some crushed garlic
and some chilies and some oil.
And you toss it
together, and it's--
DESMOND TAN: Onions.
KATE LEAHY: --what we call--
yeah, yeah.
We call it a Namhsan salad.
It didn't really have a
name, but we came across it
on the one restaurant on the
way up the mountain to the tea
farmers.
There's this little
hole in the wall place.
And it's just--
everyone's like, oh,
that's just Namhsan Restaurant.
So we stopped
there coming down--
or coming up the mountain
and coming back down.
So Namhsan Restaurant is
in the book for that dish.
DESMOND TAN: The
dish is delicious.
Nobody can resist it.
But every time we eat
it, everybody gets sick.
KATE LEAHY: No, no, we didn't.
I think the first time we did.
Well, that doesn't really--
that doesn't sell the recipe.
DESMOND TAN: Maybe we
didn't eat the-- well,
we're not selling the recipe--
KATE LEAHY: No, that's true.
DESMOND TAN: --from Burma.
KATE LEAHY: That's true.
Well, if you make it at
home, you will not get sick.
Yeah, I don't know if people
traveling in Myanmar-- there's
always a little store.
You always have to be a little
bit more careful than you would
in other parts of the world.
But we've been talking
with everyone here.
And thank you for
hanging out with us.
But we want to also open
up the floor to questions,
and see any of your burning
questions about Burma
Superstar.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming today.
What is the detailed process
for fermenting the tea leaves?
KATE LEAHY: That's
a great question.
DESMOND TAN: I think tea, they
are picked in April, June,
and in August.
I think that's
specific to Burma.
Usually, the April
picks are the best,
because it hasn't touched
water, and so forth.
KATE LEAHY: Right, because
the dry season ends--
DESMOND TAN: In August,
and it continues.
KATE LEAHY: s begins in-- yeah,
it ends in August, and then--
DESMOND TAN: It start raining
again in about May, June.
So the flavor, aroma, typically,
they're a lot more robust.
So the buds are premium.
The April tea buds are premium.
And then you have
the lower leaves
on the tea branch, and so
the June and then August.
So what happens is
that you pick the tea--
buds or the middle
layer of the branch.
Same day, you take it
back to your house.
And from there, you
steam the tea leaf,
very high temperature.
And you roll it, and you put
it in a fiber bag from there.
You bury underground about 10
by 10, 10 feet deep, 10 wide.
And on top, you have
heavy, heavy rocks
to pressure the tea so
that you squeeze out
the water, air, and so forth.
You let it sit for a minimum
two months, up to six months.
KATE LEAHY: Sometimes
two years, back
and before they had a hard
time selling it, right?
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, I
haven't tasted any of that.
KATE LEAHY: That would be extra
premium premium, double aged.
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, that would
be a little too premium for me,
yeah.
So it's a pretty easy process.
But because it happens
at such a remote area,
no one really knew
how tea is fermented.
But basically, that's it.
KATE LEAHY: Yeah,
and the key is you
have to have access
to fresh tea plants.
And when you pick them, you have
steam them right after picking,
before they can
start to turn black.
DESMOND TAN: Right.
It's how they're oxidized.
The Oolong tea-- so you have
your green tea, black tea,
and so forth.
They're oxidized.
I think maybe the correct
word is oxidation.
It's how long you oxidize the
tea that changes the color.
KATE LEAHY: These teas,
also, they're never dried.
They're always
just kind of kept--
and they start
releasing that black tea
oil, oil from the
black-- the tea leaves.
DESMOND TAN: Supposedly, the
guy say it cure baldness.
So I haven't tried.
KATE LEAHY: Well, no, I think
they also use it for hair dye.
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, well,
hair dye and baldness,
it kills two birds
with one stone.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thanks
very much for coming.
I'm a very long-time fan of
Mandalay and Burma Superstar.
DESMOND TAN: Well, thank
you, Mandalay's great.
AUDIENCE: I go to Burma
Love every single week now.
Thank you very much for
starting that, as well.
I haven't had the chance
to go to your country yet.
But I was recently in Korea.
And I was very surprised
by the big influence
that American occupation, in the
early '50s, following the war,
left in their street food.
So they eat lots of spam and
canned beans and canned corn.
So I was wondering, when the
Japanese occupied [INAUDIBLE],,
and then the British got there
to push them out, I guess,
did that also leave
any changes, I guess,
in food culture in
Burma, either from
the Japanese or British side?
KATE LEAHY: Well,
with the British side,
I would think the first
thing would be the tea house,
the tea shops, that serve
the dark tea with milk.
And in Burma, they
would use condensed milk
and evaporated milk.
But I'm sure that's just
because the British probably
preferred fresh milk,
and they just maybe
didn't have access to it.
But that tea is extremely
popular, and actually extremely
delicious, too.
DESMOND TAN: Right,
So you're talking
a little bit about
history, the Brits
went there in 1885, November 28,
1885, and went over to Burma,
forced out the
monarchy, and basically
abolished all the monarchy
that existed for over--
KATE LEAHY: That's
pretty ironic,
when you think about it--
DESMOND TAN: 1,000 years.
KATE LEAHY: --the British coming
in and abolishing a monarchy,
you know?
DESMOND TAN: Right.
So Burma became a
province of India,
but a very prosperous
one because of the rich.
There was a lot of agriculture,
a lot of best teak, best ruby.
In terms of natural
gas, right now,
they're probably number
three in the world.
So after that, because you
were talking about Japanese,
during the war, Japanese came
in, invaded for three years.
They got the British to kick
out their Japanese again.
And then from that,
communism was very popular.
I'm not sure how much
influence Americans
had in Burma or Spain.
But from there, they
basically locked themselves up
and separated themselves,
kept themselves, away
from outside world.
They abolished education,
scholarships, and so forth.
So with the Brits, there
was a lot of influence
with agriculture and processes
a system, but not with food;
I think maybe tea.
And with Japanese, so
far as I'm aware of,
it just started popping up
in the last five, six years.
And I think, if
anything, it will
be Indians who came in
between, say, 1890 to 2010,
like [INAUDIBLE] said earlier.
About two million came in.
And Chinese came in
about that time--
so about a couple of
hundred thousand--
so a lot of influence with
the Chinese and Indian,
not necessarily English
food or Japanese food.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious--
what do you think
the near future of Burmese
food is in the United States
in terms of how people
are aware of it,
how people understand it as part
of their everyday experience?
KATE LEAHY: Yeah, I'll
take that question.
I think what I
feel is sometimes,
things have to start
on the West Coast.
And then New York
has to discover it.
And then once New York
discovers it, they own it,
and they make
everyone aware of it.
I think that's what
happened with blue jeans.
So they're invented here,
and then they sent there,
and then they became popular.
DESMOND TAN: Yeah, the New
York need to talk about it.
KATE LEAHY: So New York needs
more Burmese restaurants.
But on a more
serious note, I think
what's happening-- the Bay
Area has a very diverse Burmese
population.
And I think the
future of Burmese food
is being able to go deeper
into the regions of the country
and having maybe a restaurant
that's dedicated strictly
to the Shan state.
When you go to Yangon,
there are restaurants
that are specific to different
parts of the country.
And I could see that being
the next step, that maybe 10
years from now,
instead of saying
this is a Burmese restaurant,
this is a Chin restaurant.
This is a Shan restaurant.
This is your Kayin restaurant.
And that would be
actually fascinating,
because we're just
scratching the surface
on the differences between the
different parts of the country.
And I'm excited to learn
more about those parts
of the country.
DESMOND TAN: So different
things are happening.
If you go to Burma,
they're more fascinated
with Thai food or Chinese
food or European food.
But if they have
guests, they try
to avoid taking you to
a Burmese restaurant,
because they're everywhere.
So going back to
your question, I
think the people are beginning
to just discover Burmese food.
And it could be anything.
I think that tea leaf, the
dressing is really flexible.
I mean, I think that people were
doing different things that we
or they are not doing in Burma.
In Burma-- so we used
the fermented tea
and rub it on chicken
or fish and steam it.
And it's delicious.
It's something that
we don't do in Burma.
And in Burma, because of the
availability of refrigerators--
KATE LEAHY: It's pretty
questionable in most parts
of the country.
DESMOND TAN: Freshness
is questionable.
So you cook everything to
death, just to make sure
that they're sanitized.
And I think the ingredients here
are readily available and more
fresh.
So you could do things a
little bit differently.
What's all that?
So then, maybe now, we're
talking about authenticity.
Then the question
is, what's authentic?
I think, to me,
authentic is whatever
your mom made or not what
other people are saying.
Yeah, I mean, my
aunt can make it,
and it's not authentic, because
it's not like my mom's dish.
So the same with
spaghetti-- there
are so many ways of doing it.
What's authentic?
People are just discovering it.
I don't know the direction.
I can't tell.
I mean, I can only tell you
to come to our restaurant,
invite your friends.
Go eat there all the time.
And discover where that's
going, and keep coming.
It's a difficult question.
I hate to see Burmese
who go a fusion route.
I think people
are just beginning
to discover Burmese food.
OK, so another
thing-- so growing up,
when I came to US in the early
80s, I or fellow immigrants
from Southeast Asia
were discriminated.
Maybe the food that we
ate were a little stinky.
Everybody ate
sandwich and burgers.
It's like, if I bring rice
to work, they'll beat me up.
And so it's just
interesting that now,
today, people want Burmese food.
It's nice that I don't
have to hide fish sauce.
And I can say, you know
don't know fish sauce?
Where have you been?
[LAUGHTER]
So it's .
Interesting I think we can
do a lot, move forward.
It's an open game.
You know, personally, I
love southeast Asian food
or south Asian food.
People are just
beginning to discover
the flavors of South Asia.
But also another thing--
I think with the new generation
of restaurateurs coming up,
in the past, maybe
the older generation
didn't understand quality
or maybe aesthetics
or communication or education.
So they didn't quite
meet the expectations
of a lot of the
American audience.
I think the new generations
might be different.
I think they understand quality.
They understand ambience.
They definitely know how
to communicate the food
to their customers.
So I think the Chinese,
Thai, Indian cuisines
are going to be
interesting, moving forward.
SPEAKER 1: One more question.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned the
diversity of Burmese cuisine
in the various provinces.
You've also expanded your
restaurant empire, as well.
So what's your philosophy
for opening new restaurants,
creating clones of
Burma Superstar?
How do you get each
one its own identity?
DESMOND TAN: Well, it's kind
of funny, from that little hole
in the wall restaurant, to
be referred to as an empire.
[LAUGHTER]
We have a couple of restaurants.
KATE LEAHY: One of the
things that I learned,
working with you, Desmond,
is that you always
made sure that the
restaurants were
their own individual entity.
So if you go to the-- and some
people's favorite location
is in Alameda.
And Alameda has a
totally different feel
from the one in Oakland, which
has a totally different feel
from the one on Clement Street.
And each of them act like--
each staff is almost like family
there.
And sometimes, they are family.
Sisters will be
servers together,
or brothers will work
in the kitchen together.
And I mean, you don't
have any intention
of maximizing Burma Superstar's
saturation in the city.
Burma Love is a
little bit different.
It's a restaurant that has
a little bit broader menu.
One of the reasons,
the kitchen is-- you
guys got to design that
kitchen from scratch,
so you could do certain
things in that kitchen
that you couldn't in the smaller
Burma Superstar kitchens.
And so my insider tip
is go to Burma Love
for the palata, which
is that lovely, buttery
flat bread, because I think
they have the best griddle.
And no offense to the
other restaurants,
but they have an actual--
they have a larger space.
And the way you guys do the
palata there is just perfect.
DESMOND TAN: Well, yeah, we
adapt to the environment.
So maybe a technology people
will call us dumb asses.
You have such a popularity.
Why don't you grow?
You could have 5, 10, 15, 20.
But we really haven't really--
in the last 20 years, we
opened four Burmese restaurants.
And it wasn't because we're
really ambitious or smart.
The guy from Alameda suckered
us into buying that restaurant.
It was another Burmese
restaurant called [INAUDIBLE]..
And it wasn't doing well.
So we try to be as
helpful as we can be.
So he'll call us,
hey, you know what?
I'd like to come talk to you.
I know your restaurant
is doing really well,
and see if I could pick
your brain, and so forth.
So we started talking
to this guy, Nick.
And we identified
a lot of problems.
And at first, you
know, your floors
really shouldn't be shiny.
And the mango
chicken, or whatever,
all the Chinese dishes,
needs to go away.
I think people
want Burmese food.
You should give Burmese food.
But then because his
business wasn't doing well,
he was a cater to whatever
little customers that he had.
He was very unwilling to
give up the chop suey that
was selling to whoever
that was coming in,
or the mango chicken.
So I think, in the
end, it takes time
to win a little bit of
loyalty from the customers.
Maybe he was selling
the wrong dishes.
I don't know.
A lot of things were happening.
But in the end, he
didn't want to do,
and he didn't want to
continue the business.
I think maybe the path to
a successful restaurant
was much different than
what he had thought.
So he asked me if
I wanted to buy it.
So I say, sure, why not?
So that's how we ended up
with a second restaurant;
and same with the third,
same with the fourth.
So it wasn't
because of ambition.
We weren't looking out for it.
So even tea leaf was just based
on, hey, we have bad tea leaf.
You know, I think that
we should make our own.
And then with the beer,
hey, you know what?
If Singaporean or Thai or
Chinese have their own beer,
I don't think there's
a Burmese beer.
So we have our own Burmese beer.
And on Clement Street, we
have three restaurants.
It was purely out
of really laziness,
because it's just easier
to manage if they're all
at the same place.
So why do I need to
go different places?
[LAUGHTER]
KATE LEAHY: Now you have to go
to a lot of different places.
DESMOND TAN: We bought a
coffee shop in [INAUDIBLE],,
so people could wait
at the coffee shop.
And we tell the
customer, hey, you know,
you don't have to buy anything.
But then we teach the people to
sell whenever they are there.
KATE LEAHY: That's sneaky.
DESMOND TAN: So a lot of
it is just based on need,
not because we want to
expand or have an empire.
But then, now, we have
products, products
available at some of the
natural grocery stores,
Bi-Rite, Rainbow, and
the Twitter building,
and so forth, some in the
Whole Foods, because everybody
was asking, where can I buy?
Where can I buy?
So we're working towards that.
I think pretty soon, it
will be available probably
in about two months.
So product is also just--
basically, growth
is based on need.
And I think a lot of
people do ask us to open
here or there, here and there.
We just haven't done it.
SPEAKER 1: Let's give one more
round of applause to our guest.
DESMOND TAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]